hey what's going on as bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from December 17th 2017 oh my god only
seven more days till the [ __ ] baby
Jesus comes down the chimney there
whatever the [ __ ] story is right what
was the story ball come all ye beard
guys into this [ __ ] barn look at this
little baby she was never banged Oh
poor Joseph what's going on everybody
how are you how did you enjoy your
weekend did you have a good one
my Patriots lost again I think they're
only gonna win 10 or 11 games this year
is it time to hit the panic button what
are you gonna do you know
[Music]
we had a great run we had a great run
this is a trend normally this this type
of play would not would not worry me
I've you know cuz I remember when we
lost you know Romeo Crennel and Charlie
Weis and we lost Tyla lawyer Milloy and
[ __ ] Tedy Bruschi retired we lost all
of those guys and we built it back up
again so you know this time what do we
lose we lose we lose we lost you know
Matt Patricia left to go coach the
[ __ ] lines running back to wide
receivers quarterback left tackle all of
that [ __ ] it adds up one year you know
two years that's a lot of people to lose
but back in the day you'd be like all
right you know all the draft picks they
got for them they're gonna build this
[ __ ] thing back up again right which
they always did and they continue to win
and people kept saying the Patriots it
done and they kept proving them wrong
but now I mean tom is what 41 almost 42
is that what it is or is he 40 almost 41
yeah it's like do they have time for one
more championship run
ring number six unprecedented by the way
I'm so [ __ ] sick of every time they
show the [ __ ] Steelers still like
they got six Super Bowls more than
anyone else and they never bring up the
packer since the Packers have four and
they have like 11 NFL titles that for
whatever reason they don't count
NFL titles I've been asking this
question because I'm big on that all
right I'm not saying the Steelers not
one of the great franchises of the Super
Bowl era they are but what kind of
[ __ ] league is around since the 1920s
and 1930s it doesn't count championships
until 1968 you know as I've stayed
before the Montreal Canadiens
they [ __ ] counts championships when
the Stanley Cup was the size of a
[ __ ] shot glass and then you know and
they beat the [ __ ] Montreal Maroons
playing pond hockey the [ __ ]
Philadelphia Phillies one of their World
Series titles is from the [ __ ] 1880s
I didn't think they had baseball gloves
I know what they [ __ ] they were using as
a ball you know probably like a [ __ ]
human skull it was so goddamn long ago
those championships are all counted I
don't understand what how nice are
people in Wisconsin that they don't
speak up and be like hey not for nothing
back when you could win NFL titles the
Pittsburgh Steelers were playing so we
basically been playing the same amount
of time and as far as I could tell we're
almost like 10 championships ahead of
them why do they always get all the
glory I have no [ __ ] idea I do I just
don't understand why NFL titles don't
count why don't I google that why don't
I look it up by the way congratulations
to the Steelers Jesus Christ that win
was a long time coming
should I want it [ __ ] last year when
that guy caught the ball and scored a
touchdown and then they said he didn't
after further review what she just saw
didn't happen replay the down all right
here we go let's write this out here Y
[Music]
starts with a W bill why doesn't the NFL
count NFL championships bump up a bah
doo dude why do people ignore pre Super
Bowl championships here we go
or a team's dark Aegis I don't know what
dark Aegis has to do with any of this
stuff ok so this guy goes I rarely post
on here but this always axe me I'm a fan
of the Packers but I live in the middle
of Steelers country and I get this
thrown in my face all the time that the
Steelers have won 6 Super Bowls I throw
out the fact that the Packers have won
13 championships with four of them being
Super Bowls yeah so they have more than
twice them I get all the time saying
nope they don't count and this bothers
the crap out of me yeah it absolutely
does you're basically saying that like
all the champions that came before Super
Bowl champions they're not champions
even though they want a championship as
a person who is a history major and who
loves the history of the sport
especially for some Steeler fans that
NFL history doesn't start at 1970 it
actually stole the first two Super Bowls
were called NFL title games NFL AFL
championship games or something and then
later they were they were renamed Super
Bowl champions Super Bowl one is Super
Bowl - I should say but the first one
that actually was called a Super Bowl as
it was happening was Super Bowl 3
anyways they ignore or the third AFL NFL
title chase anyways they ignore the fact
that the Steelers were terrible until
1970 also known as the dark ages of the
Steelers I think they have actually
terrible until about 72 or 73 until they
had that incredible draft I acknowledge
both that the Packers Dark Ages the 50s
and post Lombardi and holmgren I know
it's not all Steeler fans but it still
bothers the crap out of me the question
I ponder is in the title all right
all right so this guy writes it's kind
of funky since most NBA fans will count
Championships before the 76 NBA ABA
merger
I'll dude you can go you can go back
further than that with where the Los
Angeles Lakers count like a [ __ ] baa
championship as an NBA championship
it was the baa and the NBL and those two
things merged to form the NBA and like
the Minneapolis Lakers I think one the
first like four NBA titles but the year
before that they won a baa Championship
and for some reason that is counted as
an NBA championship the Lakers won an
NBA title before the NBA existed explain
how that works
anyways this isn't gonna be a good ad I
wanted something to somebody who [ __ ]
knows something Green Bay is much more
historical I think if someone wants to
argue that the league is totally
different now than the real point of
reference is in 1970 it's 1994 and the
salary cap was introduced yeah why don't
you turn it into your [ __ ] argument
math swarm of lions Browns and Eagles
fans but in all honestly it's really
frustrating flat-out interactive when
they say the Eagles have never won
anything yeah that's [ __ ] this is
from four years ago
you can't cherry pick which championship
titles count and which don't the name of
the trophy is arbitrary it's not
arbitrary at all it's it has a very
specific line in the sand and it's one
that the league itself drew not friends
fans trying to hold down the Eagles and
other teams the NFL decided nothing
pre-super Bowl matters yeah well that's
my question why cherry-picking would be
saying the Eagles of Packers pre Super
Bowl championships count but the Browns
don't arbitrary would be saying the
package Packers NFL championships count
but the Eagles don't just because the
NFL only counting stats and
championships since Superbowl one may or
may not be fair but it's definitely not
arbitrary or cherry-picking all right
that's all good points
but it doesn't explain why they decided
not to decide why people count why do
people do not see there's a bunch of
articles on it there's a bunch of
articles I oh these are all chat rooms
I'm not gonna get anywhere with this
next time I do one of these [ __ ] I I
don't know who would you ask is somebody
there's got to be somebody that you
asked because this [ __ ] [ __ ] that
they act like you know the [ __ ]
league is like 70 goddamn years old and
they're acting like the top of the heap
is six measly [ __ ] championships it
doesn't make sense at all and then you
know something if they actually count an
NFL titles I know that Giants won a
couple two and they got four Super Bowls
and the only thing that I'm basing this
on is that the NBA the NHL and certainly
Major League Baseball all go back to the
1920s and MLB goes back to like 1889 I
don't know it's weird it's just a weird
[ __ ] thing that like the Patriots
have only been good you know winning
championships in 18 - last 18 years and
we're one championship a wave in 18
years we somehow are only one
championship away from being the most
successful tied for the most successful
chip NFL team of all time that makes no
[ __ ] sense it makes no [ __ ] sense
people anyways I missed most of the
Patriots Steelers game I caught the
first quarter first half I basically
caught and then you know I'm a dad now
so I had to go to a kid birthday party
and once again every time I go to one of
these parties I am so feel so blessed
that I had a daughter and not a son
Jesus Christ they're [ __ ] lunatics
lunatics I was just I used to be like
that you go in there with your daughter
and the first thing you're doing you
just [ __ ] you know you become like
the Dave Semenko and your kids like
[ __ ] Wayne Gretzky because you know
somebody's going to
something you know somebody's gonna
throw a ball come flying off a slide
they have their [ __ ] lunatic she this
is a funniest thing I was watching this
kid who look like a little Bobby Hurley
he was playing this game you know
hitting the ball like using his like
both his arms like interlocked in his
his fingers and he bounced the ball and
then use his forearms like a bat and
smash it against the wall and then stop
it with his hand and throw it back
between his legs you know all
point-guard style and you look like a
little Bobby Hurley so I was getting a
kick out of this kick although this kid
this kids this kid's got he had it you
know what I mean like he had like that
competitive thing and then at one point
he ran over to go pick up the ball and
there was like a couple of there almost
like you know those those yoga blocks
that help you if you're not stretchy
enough they will like that but they were
more like cushions and someone had made
a little seed out of him and I had kind
of been sitting there like oh this is
nice some parent did that because they
didn't want to sit on the hard floor and
I was standing up when the kid came over
and he picks up the ball and just sees
like two blocks with a bigger block on
top of it and he just kicks it over
there was no reason to do it you know
and I was really just looking at that
thinking like like wow is did I just see
right there in that moment why why
there's war why the world is so [ __ ]
up why we don't get along because we're
like literally wired to just [ __ ]
destroy stuff and I'll tell you
something else with all these [ __ ]
people out there who are trying to say
that like gender gender roles are
basically taught to kids yeah from what
I saw when I've seen it these kid
birthday parties that is just not it's
not even remotely the case boys are
[ __ ] lunatics anything they can pick
up they're gonna throw anything they can
just knock over and break they're gonna
do it the girls are like sitting down
like behaving themselves I can't
necessarily say shake sharing after a
certain age they're not really sharing
but they're definitely like their
interactions with boys it's just kind of
like
what the [ __ ] was that like they just
kind of this sitting it with the toy and
a boy just runs up and rips it out of
their hands and you just see them
looking at it like like you know if you
ask me for it you know I I wouldn't give
it to you you know so it's gonna be
interesting with all of these families
out here that are trying to prove I
might be wrong but as far as me just
sitting there it's just boys are
absolute [ __ ] lunatics lunatics I
told you last year we I might my
daughter's birthday party they came over
immediately it'll pick it up gravel in
the yard throwing it down on throwing it
at [ __ ] cars climbing up on [ __ ]
every two seconds hey get down from
there get down from there you know girls
would just go into like the doll house
or pick up a toy and they would just sit
there and play with it beyond beyond
more mature than the boys the boys I
swear to god it's like it's like I can't
say puppies still like do you know after
a dog it's just after it's a dog and it
knows how to run they're like that age
you know where they're gonna go get
sprayed by a skunk yeah [ __ ]
hilarious but um we had a great time and
they had like like we went out to this
place of good friends of ours and it was
that the one of those parties that
wasn't at the house it was I got a
destination so there was one room that
had all these games and after you're
done with that game then you go into
another place with a bunch of other
games and then in the end you know all
the kids get food you know and they're
sitting there eating pizza and [ __ ] and
all of a sudden the cakes company you
know you know just the meltdowns are
coming everybody's like going alright
alright trying to time it they had the
cake we sang happy birthday they're
starting to whine I feel look like if we
leave now the meltdowns only gonna
happen like halfway on the way back but
fortunately my daughter loves music so
whenever we drive home whenever she
starts like flipping out me and Nia just
starts singing to her you know we just
took away all the itsy-bitsy spider I
will say
what's the other one the wheels on the
bus go round and round that one she
likes Jesus Christ
who's calling already it's it's early in
the morning people who who could this be
who could this boss oh [ __ ] I gotta take
this hang on hello I'm back I just said
hello like I just click back to you guys
um yeah anyways we just sing all these
friggin songs and then she wants to sing
along with us and themes a shows you
know
Papapa puppy dog path she loves that
[ __ ] I'll tell you the show I've been
talking about it I just don't [ __ ]
like it I just don't like that fancy
Nancy hmm I just don't like every every
show
she's like being a douche and
self-involved and like totally shallow
and then she allegedly learns a lesson
and then the next show she's just a jerk
again
there's like no growth whatsoever in
this person you know what I mean
I mean vampa reen always wants to go
back to Transylvania but she's not
hurting anybody she just gets a little
bummed out every once in a while that
the other kids aren't blue like her
right but [ __ ] Fancy Nancy this
little ginger brought over there dude
she's hanging out with a girlfriend
right and they're sitting there they
gonna do a [ __ ] dance and she's like
I'm gonna be the Sun and you be Arana be
a rainbow you be the Sun and her friends
like I want to be a peacock she goes
yeah but yeah you can't cuz the rainbow
and a peacock doesn't make any sense
it's got to be the Sun and the rainbow
she goes why I want to be a peacock and
she's like look jinn say that but that's
the subtext so then they have this big
[ __ ] falling-out you know cuz she's
being a [ __ ] again like she is every
[ __ ] episode every episode she's into
like like what's the fanciest stuff
coming up with a clubhouse that's just
her and exclusively her own you know she
I swear to god dude God but I tell you
this right now in the animated world god
bless the animated
and that marries her someday [ __ ]
lunatic [ __ ] that's gonna be one of
those [ __ ] chicks right he'd just buy
him everything on it every designer
keeping up with the Kardashian [ __ ]
love bracelet you could possibly do and
then a [ __ ] in when she's leaving you
and you're sitting there going but I
bought you all this stuff she'll be like
I never wanted that I just wanted a
connection look I swear to god there's
gonna be a first 48 with an adult
[ __ ] fancy-dancy if she doesn't get
her act together she is she's gonna
drive somebody to do something crazy
because she doesn't learn any [ __ ]
lessons and she's really shallow you
know she's a little sociopath I just I
just don't like sunny and she does some
[ __ ] dance to apologize to a friend
and once again a friend's gonna be
friends with her again rather than just
being like hey you know something I've
been on this ride before your little red
[ __ ] I'm not [ __ ] doing this again
it's like literally teaching somebody
how to stay in a dysfunctional
relationship every [ __ ] episode at
least the ones I'm paying attention to I
just don't like it you know I don't be
that person just sitting there say they
don't have your kid watch that but like
you know I don't put my foot down too
much as a parent with my wife
well who's kidding hood I put it down
but it's not listened to because it's
the dad foot and nobody gives it nobody
gives a [ __ ] about the dead it's all
about the mom foot the mom says it ain't
happening anymore it ain't happening
anymore the dad says that they did
people just they just yes'm to death and
then the next day it's like why is she
watching why she watchin carrot-top here
again huh why is she watching this stuff
bill it's fine it's just a cartoon it's
just it's just what you wanted it's just
what you wanted I don't like that show
anyways puppy-dog pals that's where it's
at okay
there are a couple of pals there trying
to help out somebody in need you know
what I mean and you know something yeah
Bob goes through a lot of little
problems but he's not hurting anybody
salt to the earth guy you know probably
could do some squats
you know shoulders a little too broad
for his little skinny
I don't know what's going on there but
other than that I don't have a problem
you know so anyways plowing ahead
I watched Liverpool verse that game I
saw a little bit of the Dolphins Vikings
how about the Browns but the [ __ ]
Cleveland Browns got a chance to make
the playoffs this is really gonna be a
fun year my Patriots are not gonna win
it this year okay what's looking like
they're not I just hope they lose the
[ __ ] first round just so I can enjoy
all these other goddamn teams that are
going to be in it it's got to be it's
really gonna be exciting and all of a
sudden you know the Rams have lost a
couple they're showing that they're not
invincible
the [ __ ] charges are coming on you
know there's a [ __ ] chance someone
would say to me yesterday that that they
could actually be the NFC and AFC
Championship games could both be played
in Los Angeles I don't know about that
could the Chargers get home-field
advantage
I don't know if they could do that
mathematically at this point bi
apologized a music better I'm better up
on the sports but I just you know I got
the kid now so you know it's only kid
wants something has to give and it's not
going to be her so I did watch Liverpool
verse man United Liverpool scored the
first goal and was really carrying the
play and then all of a sudden man United
just really had possession of the ball
in Liverpool's and and kind of seemed
like basketball or it's like you know
it's a game a runs you know and at one
point I said something where I was just
like we got to get the [ __ ] ball back
I said we and I was like ah [ __ ] is this
something else I care about I don't
totally care about but I do find it
interesting to watch and I'm actually
starting to get into the game and I
remember back in the day when I would
hear the crowd applaud when no goal was
scored but they were just applauding the
pressure you were putting on I started
like without thinking about it doing
that yesterday I was like f [ __ ] here we
go again I'm gonna start giving a [ __ ]
about something else anyways but I'm
actually going to go on I should go
online now and see if Liverpool
a [ __ ] game I know I'm gonna be out
there at some point that would be sick
if I went out there and now I'm not
gonna sing you're never gonna be alone
or whatever the [ __ ] they sing I mean
some do she watched three games at all
of a sudden we gonna go buy a scarf and
stand there like I [ __ ] bled their
colors I'm not doing that I'm just a
[ __ ] let's see here just a [ __ ]
newbie fan here all right what do we get
billboard.com oh by the way did I
mention I'm gonna be in Europe January
4th
through where our January 4th through
the 13th
all right Liverpool I'm there on the
26th now here's the interesting thing
that's the first that is the first date
on that tour which means if they have a
[ __ ] game on the 25th at home there's
a chance there is a chance I could
actually go to that [ __ ] game
Liverpool [ __ ] schedule all right
what do we got here come on come on one
[ __ ] time work out for me 119 to 14
to 27 it looks like it's an away game
right who the [ __ ] do they just play
yeah they just played Man Man Man United
right oh wait no they got a home game 12
p.m. [ __ ] I'm going Liverpool vs Watford
I'm gonna [ __ ] go they got one verse
man you know they're at in Manchester on
the 24th alright don't get greedy bill
don't get greedy
you know what I mean don't get greedy
I'm gonna see if I can go to that one on
the 27th it says 12 p.m. the wait is but
it's probably gonna be at night I'm
thinking 12 p.m.
Liverpool time but it's not gonna be is
it it's gonna be my time there eight
hours ahead that doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense the games at 10:00 at
night maybe that's an East Coast time
and it's at 7:00 I don't really that
would be at 5:00
don't [ __ ] know I'll figure something
out Jesus Christ is gonna be a nobody at
my [ __ ] show we would love to have
gone bill alright
no booze everybody Oh both freckles came
close he [ __ ] came close a couple of
times he's 22 days in can he make the
entire month I'm right there man
I'm right [ __ ] there I just make it
through Christmas Day
I'll have gone 31 days and I'll have my
own sober October from November 21st
through December 25th that oh yeah
that's six days right 25 and 6 is 31
it's the longest goddamn once you can
have tell you what's going pretty good
it's going pretty great what's wild
night and I really look at the balls
it's like do I really want to start
doing that again I don't [ __ ] do that
I got I got to stay in shape let me be
taping a special next year right I got
to stay in [ __ ] shape alright let's
let's read only a couple of [ __ ] ad
reads this week okay uh do me on DS me
on DS the Patriots [ __ ] lose doo doo
doo doo bi DS me undies don't turn to
the [ __ ] booze they had a great run
Brady is old but he's not the fault
that's what I'm told it's the other con
start doing their job he's still
throwing for 300 yards a game even
though he's 41 years old Tom Brady is
still the [ __ ] he's the human version of
me on DS all right me undies uses the
coveted micro modal motile fabric which
is three times softer than cotton if you
never felt this fabric get ready to
experience pure bliss in underwear form
you can also get a style that is
perfectly suited for you or that special
someone seriously these fun undies would
be great stockings but why stop at
undies the undies has cozy lounge pants
and onesies in that same supersoft
fabric perfect for wearing Christmas
morning
Andie's has a great offer from my
listeners for any first-time purchasers
when you purchase enemy undies you get
15% off and free shipping order by 1216
for free shipping in time for Christmas
crunch for time you can't go wrong with
the me undies gift cards this is a
no-brainer
get a get 50% off a pair of the most
comfortable undies you will ever put on
to get your 15% off your first pair free
shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee
go to me undies calm / / that's me
undies calm / BER alright
o stamp stuff you know I don't have any
stocking stuffer for my wife huh how do
I take the stocking and they stuff it in
the mouth the oh Jesus stamps calm as
you know the holiday season Dobie Dobie
do are the busiest time of the [ __ ]
year especially at the post office
stamps.com brings all the service of the
u.s. post office right to your desktop
buy and print official US postage from
any letter any package any class of mail
using your own computer and printer then
mail the mail carrier picks it up print
postage anytime a day anytime any day
any time stands comm is always open
stamps.com not only saves you time it
saves you money
stamps.com can help you print the right
amount of postage every time never
overpay again remember that that's that
little asian girl acting like she's a
black woman on a 70s sitcom how does she
not get in trouble stamps comm helps you
print the right amount of postage every
time never overpay again with stamps
comm you get discounts on postage you
can't even get at the post office with
all the time and money you'll save
stamps comb is the best gift you can
give yourself this holiday season I use
stamps comm because yet I don't like
going to the post office either if I
don't have to I send out all my posters
and right now you too can enjoy the
stamps.com service with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale without long
term commitments
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
bur that stamps comm enter ber righty-o
you know what I made for the first time
all the second time my first time I
[ __ ] him up I made some chocolate chip
cookies not good at making the cookies
and this time they finally came out
right because I made three different
batches where I just opened the same
batch I did three different cooks of
them I only had like one cookie sheet
and I had to like you know my recipe
called for only half a tablespoon of a
dollop and I was like that seems really
small I didn't get how much they spread
out it's like reverse bacon with bacon
like all shrivels up like the cookie
dough spreads up so my first one that I
made it like the host sheet looked like
a giant cookie I was like alright that's
not the way to do it and then the next
one were like medium sized and then I
quote sign it kinda had like the smaller
ones but um they would damn good and I
used my little KitchenAid thing you know
second pair of hands not free
advertising I just loved that [ __ ]
thing I love when that things turning
and I'm over in the counter doing
something else but I learned from the
expert my mother she told me you know
she's like well how did you do it you
know I'm like well you know I put him in
the kitchen now she's like you got to
fold the flour and you can't use that he
can't use the kitchen anything you want
to fold it and she's trying to say
because it you get some air in there I
don't know somebody else was saying it
has to do with gluten I have no idea
because my cookie seemed a little bit
runny yet crispy and every oven is the
different is different so I used a
classic our version my family's version
of the classic Toll House recipe in
chocolate chip cookies were invented by
a couple of ladies in Massachusetts at
this place this like Toll House tavern
or something like that and they they
would use like a semi-sweet chocolate
chip and that's what I always use but I
got you know my wife told me that she
likes milk chocolate so I said fine so I
put the milk chocolate ones in there and
everybody said they didn't say they were
good they were like this is the best
goddamn chocolate chip cookie I ever
tasted so maybe I'll do a cooking video
on that [ __ ] but I can't give away my
family recipe so I don't know how to
[ __ ] do it
then having said that I fired up my big
green egg for the first time in a long
time and I had these two [ __ ] rib
eyes with like literally the [ __ ] the
rib bones sticking out you could have
[ __ ] brain somebody with it when they
were frozen and I got impatient with my
green egg I was told 250 with indirect
heat it went up to like 3/10 so I was
like alright I'll leave it in there for
like 40 45 minutes instead of doing the
full hour and I then I reversed seared
it when I was on the stove I should only
done that for a minute and ended up
being under salted and overcooked two
beautiful pieces of meat and I [ __ ] it
up
I just really [ __ ] it just it made me
sick because those things were in my
freezer for a while but I still ate it
and I will not waste it I'm gonna eat
I'm gonna remember next time to be more
patient that's the biggest thing with
the big green egg you gotta be [ __ ]
patient and I'm just not cuz that thing
is the [ __ ] it will just stay at the
temperature you want and I just you know
it was getting late we were coming back
from the party I just wanted to put him
on here that you know when you put it on
and I ended up [ __ ] him up so anyways
you know I think Alanis Morissette said
it best when she said what did she say
something had about being ironic no she
said you live you learn you shop did you
learn why didn't she ever have a really
good follow-up to that that jagged
little pill why cuz she got it all out
it's almost like she should have saved
some of the anger for like the next
album you know like you when you were
watching a baseball playoff and your
team scores 11 runs you know wins like
11 2 and as I scoring like runs number 8
9 10 there's always some baseball fan be
like save it for tomorrow night
why he scored all of them now maybe she
should have done that I don't know baby
built maybe you ought to put out a hit
[ __ ] album before you criticize
somebody else's [ __ ] one of the
album's of the decade
Jagged Little Pill ah [ __ ] rip your
balls off have your scrotum there
whatever the [ __ ] is I don't know how it
goes I don't know the anatomy aren't
your balls in your scrotum the same
thing they've no idea you know what I
mean that's like it's a snare drum but
the things underneath that are called is
the snares it's very confusing I saw you
with pay you know can you imagine a guy
if you wrote a [ __ ] song like that I
remember every breath you take they were
like the sunked it's it's this guy's a
stalker she puts out a song Hey sounded
like a flood she's looking in the guy's
[ __ ] house terrifying [ __ ] song
and of course when women do it oh isn't
she strong and brave poisoned your
morning tea anyway so plowing ahead here
guess what I'm doing today at 12:00 noon
I'm gonna go fly a helicopter there I
flew Saturday for the first time since
the end of October and I had the best
[ __ ] time flew great pickups and set
downs were [ __ ] is great as they've
ever been and I had taken a lot of time
off dare I say I'm getting [ __ ] good
at I landed on top of a building which
I've never done before it's [ __ ]
awesome and I felt like I was in some
like [ __ ] cop or procedural show you
know where is the patient oh he's coming
in now you know the beginning is to play
in the opening credits wreck old pilot
he's almost [ __ ] CD through it was
always really intimidating because I
felt like I would always be like really
windy and stuff like that but uh I'm
sure it could have been but it was kind
of perfect conditions came in there was
plenty of room there wasn't anything
sticking up I always felt like when you
would go there was just sort of like
you know I've have had to land those
things on I don't know what you call
them
it's like rather than just setting it
down on the ground there's like a little
square helipad that you'll and that's
actually sitting on the ground and you
have to be way more accurate then you
start getting in your head you stir in
the pot you get a little wind what the
[ __ ] going on and then the instructor
has to come on the controls with you and
then your friends in the back don't
respect you as much you know it's one of
those deals speaking of friends in the
back I'm gonna be flying with my
instructor and and Joe Rogan's coming
along I've been trying to figure out
some time when we could actually do that
we finally have a little bit of time in
our schedules gonna fly with him and
then on Wednesday I'm gonna be doing the
Joe Rogan experience podcast and we'll
be talking about the flight maybe I have
some video hopefully or whatever it's
gonna be a great time so please tune
into that and I will be promoting season
3 if f is for family and of course the
the Patrice O'Neal stand-up comedy
benefit which is happening February 19th
2019 trying to get last the rid of the
last couple hundred tickets on Joe's
podcast alright with that I've already
read the the advertising let's let's
read a little bit of the questions here
let's read some of the questions I got
to get back to the [ __ ] gym man I've
been being mr. mom you know now that
I've been off the road you know because
I you know want to be with my kid and
every morning I just you know there's
always a reason you know
not to go to the gym where I'm just like
or I could sit here and read her a book
you know or we could go to the
playground or I could take her for a
walk you know or I could watch a driver
a little electric car around and then
old clio do is in town my trainer who
now owns the dog you know whenever he
comes into town he brings her and it was
awesome going on a couple of hikes with
her and stuff I [ __ ] love that dog
but she looks great if anybody's
concerned and she has a dog friend now
which I didn't have the skill set to
make her comfortable around another dog
so if she's like
she's living her best life so she really
is like an amazing story where she was
abandoned you know by the LA River she
had all these issues my one of my wife's
friends found her my wife took her in we
kept her for eight years she lived in
the lap of luxury it got too crazy you
know she bit one of my friends you know
all of this stuff usually ends with a
pit bull getting put down and this dog
just keeps going to an even better
situation and now it has like you know
it's the dog is like 10 years old now so
I mean it's in you know probably the
final four or five years of its life and
it's gonna live you know now as a best
friend you know to hang out with it's
really awesome it's really awesome and I
still get to see her once every couple
of months and you know so I'm happy
because I felt like when I got that dog
I felt like a responsibility like this
thing is he's gonna live a full life
it's not going to get put down I didn't
anticipate that I'd have to you know
give her away to somebody else but I
made sure that when I did she had a good
home so I feel like I did the right
thing you know all right
anyways that's my little aren't I a
great guy you know talking about myself
very Instagram influenced Bosnia show
come to Bosnia you lying ginger [ __ ]
well I thought I was going there you
[ __ ] douche I'm [ __ ]
you can't jump on a [ __ ] train let me
know I'm gonna find out how long that
these [ __ ] [ __ ] over there I'm
literally going to Estonian lot for you
like how much more do I have to [ __ ]
do for you guys come to Bosnia alright
well that was Bosnia let's find out
isn't it just southeast of of Prague
it's not that far is it isn't it just
like a [ __ ] train ride away let's see
here let's see how close I mean I'm only
flying from the other side of the globe
you can't get on a plane for a couple of
[ __ ] hours all right so there's
Bosnia alright that's Jesus that's
that's a hell of a [ __ ] ride my fault
where
am I gonna be I'm gonna be in Vienna all
right let's let me see something
Bosnia to Vienna traveled just a
distance right I'm the worst with Google
and [ __ ] Bosnia to to Vienna distance 8
hours and 32 minutes holy [ __ ] that's a
[ __ ] Drive all right my fault I'm
starting to understand your argument
plane ride let's see how long this is
it's an hour and 15 minutes by plane
Jesus Christ like how much can that cost
that's like flying from here to Vegas
you jump on Southwest for like 80 bucks
all right good lord I apologize next
time sir or ma'am or transgendered
person whatever the [ __ ] you are I will
try and get to Bosnia all right I
thought I was going there you lion
ginger [ __ ] isn't it weird somebody from
that part of the world to be judging
somebody I'll try to get my ass down
there all right and now here he comes
all the all this [ __ ] about Europe now
I'm getting all this advice on places to
go things to do and the problem is I'm
not really gonna have a lot of time
alright tip about Poland
dear mr. bill I'm very excited about
your Europe tour so am i I'm very
excited to go to Poland I'm polish but
for now I'm living and working in Sweden
so I hope to get the ticket for one of
your stand-ups in Stockholm or in Oslo
one tip about Poland use it how you want
in one of your late-night shows visit
you called Poland in Eastern European
country and that you were excited about
visiting there happy to hear that but
well we polish hate the term Eastern
European for a few reasons I imagine one
of them's gonna be the Russians first is
that if you look at
a map of Europe geographically we're not
on the east well then explain to me why
the Detroit Red Wings for so [ __ ]
long you know we're in the East weren't
they are they still on East Coast time
anyways so it's the same like Nebraska
is on the East Coast I'd say more like
Michigan and second reason political is
that this term comes from times when we
were under the Soviet Union yes we fight
back
got our end up we fought back out our
independence we are happy and proud
about that I'm sure that you never mean
to offend us also we are not
hypersensitive [ __ ] now you Polish
people seem [ __ ] cool I wish you a
great time during the European tour
kick-ass performance and lots of
positive energy so as always go [ __ ]
yourself Mike guy named Mike from Poland
anyways alright
point taken point [ __ ] take it Jesus
Christ well let me let me look at the
[ __ ] map of Europe here all right
Europe map come on type it correctly
wiki [ __ ] pedia why why would it go
to [ __ ] wiki [ __ ] kunti pedia I
[ __ ] it I love what he pedia but
jesus [ __ ] christ
why does it always go to [ __ ]
Wikipedia I don't I don't get it
just don't [ __ ] get it alright let's
see yeah I don't know about this I don't
know you slightly [ __ ] east oh I see
cuz that much of Russia wait a minute
why don't I look up Eastern you Eastern
Europe map see what we got here
oh I got news for you buddy I just
looked up Eastern Europe maps and you're
[ __ ] right in there Eastern Europe is
Poland Czech Republic Slovakia Hungary
Hungary Croatia they don't have Austria
in there yeah this might be because the
these are the these are the countries
that Russia was uh had control of yeah
maybe that is what it is let's see it
more ok Eastern European map
how about 2019 how about you let me
[ __ ] click on it and that Jesus
Christ in 2019 boom I gotta be honest
with you dude they're still [ __ ]
they're still got you included in this
yeah they got you in it listen send me
the [ __ ] whatever [ __ ] map you're
looking at I don't know what it is oh
you know something I give up I give up
you I don't bill what have you listened
to the guy that [ __ ] lives over there
am I really doing that oh I think guy
who actually lived in Poland this is me
from Los Angeles I think you're wrong
about where you live might was I really
just doing that for the last five
minutes I apologize ah told you where
you live
Rose Bowl everybody hey
Billy rose balls first of all a big fan
of all your work thank you I was at your
Seattle Show and you and Dean Del Ray
we're hilarious thank you anyways my
school is in the Rose Bowl this year and
since you're such a veteran I was
wondering if you had any advice for a
first-timer I have the basic tailgating
stuff like a grill beer and a cooler
should I bring anything special thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself
Alex Alex bring a chair bring some lawn
chair someplace to sit down depending if
you want to hang afterwards and let all
the traffic leave I would bring some
firewood that you can put into your
little hibachi and start a little fire
and stay warm one of the things that
people forget don't forget plates
don't forget napkins bring a trash bag
to put all your [ __ ] in condiments
utensils a table you don't be sitting
there having everything in your [ __ ]
lap what else charcoal I bring those
little squares that make it easy to
light that if you get in the the
wood-burning sort of whatever they
[ __ ] that natural wood charred crap
if you're gonna do that unless you
unless you have the match light stuff a
lighter beer bottle opener butter for
the buns buns it's just everything I
just go over and over and over ed solo
cups
booze I had a jacket for when it gets
cold when you get your tickets try to
stay on the side with the with the
pressbox on it that way you're not
staring into the Sun for half the
[ __ ] game oh and before you leave
even when you go to take a piss when
you're tailgating find where you are
because you're on a golf course it's all
going to look the same the stadium is
round especially at night there's no
focal
that you're gonna be able to find and
you will walk around lost all right
there'll be these little balloons
they're finally lighting them up for
years they did not light them up it's
literally one two three four five six
seven eight nine I don't know how high
up it goes but just make sure you
remember where you are
pace yourself depending on what time
you're gonna go bring a cigar if you're
a cigar person bring a light or bring a
cutter all of that [ __ ] you think that
you you're gonna you're gonna forget all
right it's a good luck to you all right
daughter mmm eh eh Billy red nose boobs
Billy the red-nosed pubie I am a 33 year
old lay and I'm also a second degree
black belt in Gojira Gojira karate I've
done martial arts for the last eight
years that I have also dabbled in other
styles and learned a lot of things from
many different instructors that's
awesome the reason I am writing to you
is because I listen to you on Conan
Conan needs a friend podcast and you've
mentioned you wanted your daughter to
learn MMA or something but your wife
might not be thrilled about the idea I
was hoping you could tell her that as a
small woman I'm only 5 feet that knowing
something to protect myself makes me
feel better being outside or in crowds I
think of it as having insurance you hope
you never need it but it's nice to have
yeah absolutely I think all women should
know how to do this [ __ ] and they should
learn it without it being broadcast out
there that they're learning it because
then the perverts will then start taking
classes and try and roll around the mat
with you not only they'll have a defense
against whatever you do you should
spring the [ __ ] on them not only will
you [ __ ] be able to defend yourself
you actually be able to catch the
[ __ ] douche that's doing it and they
can lock them up in a perfect world all
right there are instructors who are very
caring and our fathers themselves they
will give your daughter tips and extra
advice on how to face men since
generally speaking men are stronger I
don't know I don't think there's
anything wrong with sending your
daughter to dancing school sometimes
that can help
with your art my friend at the dojo also
did ballet but she said it helped with
her footwork I have a daughter that's
three years old and when she's a little
older I will be enrolling her at my
school which my husband and also our son
attends daily being a martial artist
wouldn't make your daughter unfeminine
when you rather she be a little femme
fatale it's preaching to the choir here
exactly there's any questions I'd love
to answer and will write back Merry
Christmas and go [ __ ] yourself yeah
thank you I'm gonna I got to read that
to my wife and she'll be like I never
said that she can back and dad it's like
yet you did you did on some level or at
least that's the way I heard that's the
way I heard it anyways I've been doing
well with my anger everybody been doing
well with it like I immediately am now I
when I flip out I start to apologize as
I'm doing it and say that I'm being a
baby and there has to be a more mature
way to settle this and I swear to God if
you're an angry guy out there I cannot
tell you what that means to the woman in
your life they like they become the
person they were when when you met him
you know a lot of times when your wife
or girlfriend changes it's because
you're changing and they're reacting to
what you're doing you know what I mean
not to give women a hundred percent a
[ __ ] pass before all the women listen
to this guy that's guys looking at the
[ __ ] boyfriend a husband one thing
women love to do is [ __ ] rubbin and
they can't just be right then they got
ya see look at it I can push your face
right down to the paper where it says
they're right
so yeah that's gonna be my thing and I'm
gonna I think I might go back to therapy
next year just specifically to talk
about my anger and get this thing sorted
out and you know and I keep threatening
that I might start going to Sunday
church again regularly even though I
don't believe in any of it I like it
just as a way to reset and just kind of
sit and think as I block out all the
[ __ ] that's being said to me just
sit there
and think you'd be like what's important
what do I need to do you know get your
[ __ ] together you know don't be a dick
life is flying by alright friend wants
to get matching tattoos oh geez alright
hey Billy burnips so I've known this
girl for going on five years now we both
still remember the night we met and had
developed a close intimate relationship
sense emply we were together officially
earlier this year then broke up and it
was during this time she got a tattoo to
symbolize the loss she felt after our
breakup
we've since started talking again and we
went to a we went out to a concert
together in San Francisco and fell in
love all over again well since we've
returned she asked me how I'd feel about
getting a tattoo matching hers ya know
yet don't do that
we're not officially back together but I
think that meaning behind this tattoo is
deeper than that I feel like I'm
connected to this girl regardless if I'm
with her or not so I wouldn't regret it
even if I didn't talk to her ever again
I'm leading towards yes as obviously I
really like this girl but I need an
outsider's perspective it'd be my first
and probably only tattoo and it's not
and it's nothing ridiculous just a word
on the forearm no name or anything like
that she's beautiful
and we get along like best friends as
well as lovers what do you think yeah
dude I you don't get a matching tattoo
with a woman ever and that maybe if
you're 25 years into being married and
the kids have all moved out of the house
you don't do that don't don't [ __ ] do
that okay because you've already broken
up it seems like a very volatile
emotional relationship you know you're
my soul mate I love you [ __ ] you we're
breaking it up I got a tattoo
talking about how sad a wasn't we broke
up and now we're getting back together
and now we need to get matching tattoos
I mean this is it's well I wouldn't win
the when the emotions level off a little
okay and you're in the grind of a
relationship and you guys don't run from
that they can actually hang there's no
[ __ ] reason to do that because if you
end up [ __ ] breaking up which who's
kidding who that sounds like there's a
50/50 chance you will now you got this
[ __ ] tattoo on your arm and then
you're gonna get with your next person
you know the person you end up maybe the
person you end up being with and she's
gonna be like what's that and you know
this is this tattoo that I got from a
past relationship that another woman
also is walking around with and she's
skinny thing if you [ __ ] think that
that's gonna stay there the only reason
why I would say to do it is because
there's still that laser [ __ ] surgery
don't get like regret or missing you her
butterfly whatever the [ __ ] my butterfly
whatever the [ __ ] she has an arm all
right she [ __ ] up she did that you
didn't so you know this is but you know
this is a good like lock the door test
in the relationship to be like yeah I
don't want to do that I don't have any
tattoos I'm not a tattoo guy I respect
the fact that you did that
I respect what that means and what that
means on your arm is in my heart I don't
need to draw it on my arm and if that me
is a deal-breaker and you're gonna break
up with me then then that that's [ __ ]
great I didn't do it okay don't do it
yeah me sir do not you know let me ask
you this if you got the tattoo and she
didn't do it would you break up with her
the answer is [ __ ] no then why the
[ __ ] should that be a deal-breaker the
other way around if the answer is yes
then you're [ __ ] crazy and I hope
she's crazy too and you have a positive
kid two negatives make a positive I
don't I don't want to [ __ ] I just
wouldn't do it I wouldn't do it all
right I thought many times in my younger
time life of getting a tattoo and I
never did and I'm so glad I didn't now
because I feel like not having a tattoo
is like rebellious but not even
rebellious it's unique
especially now you know I saw the first
[ __ ] person that wasn't like a pop
star walking down the street with like a
[ __ ] face tattoo and they were coming
across the street I was like what in the
[ __ ] is that like I didn't know like III
couldn't tell why the person just looked
different until they got up close and
slike oh my god oh my god they drew on
their face you draw on my face dude
destroys Airport ticket machine aah oh
please tell me this is true that
literally made my entire body just relax
hey hey BAE Billy ginger-nuts a lot of
stuff about my privates this week
everybody you know there's a lot other
things you can make fun of you might
like this one massive Korean man
destroys all the airport auto ticket
machines because his one ain't working
well you know something I kind of like
this until he had a wreck everybody
else's I spent a fair bit of time at
this Airport and the dudes with the
machine guns always seen to be right
next to me anyway if you get some time
out of your fancy celebrity interview
podcast I knew I was gonna get [ __ ] for
that and want to see a normal slash and
saying can't lose his [ __ ] check it out
thanks for the company it's been great
for the last five years or so best
regards to you and yours and go [ __ ]
yourself all right I got a click on this
yeah go to page oh my god how did I miss
out on this I haven't been on my Twitter
account for a couple days so maybe
people sent me this ha ha ha ha ha ha oh
here we go come on this is all written
in Korean I love it this seems like the
real deal here we go oh don't do this to
me
all right he's smashing his luggage on
this thing people are looking at him
just staring it he's taking his carry-on
he just tipped it over and he tipped two
of them over where is the security now
he just sort of pushed a woman Wow
oh now he's going after another one I
love this guy
G oh my god okay there goes number four
dude this is like the NFL Combine a
going psycho like this guy just put up
insane numbers he's first-round draft
pick
he does have a sense of entitlement
though somehow he's standing there with
his hand on his hip with his suit where
is the security Wow
all right I really [ __ ] enjoyed that
good advertisement so where can i buy
this suitcase very durable he's a common
this is the English comment you are
looking for because they're all in
Korean yeah he probably he got a vision
of what will happen in the future you
saw the plane crushed so he tried to
stop everyone on board to board it being
positive those of you who are wondering
this is what happened a businessman
named Oh died sue is arrested for
drunkenness missing his daughter's
fourth birthday and his friend Joo Quan
picks him up from the police station
they go to the phone booth calls home
okay this is just bull this is just all
[ __ ] oh my god I hate how
everybody's trying to just make a funny
comment how come nobody saying like oh
my god this is [ __ ] great yo if this
was in the States he would have got
chopped in the [ __ ] throat
after the first chaos went down Korea
you got to work on your anger management
issues there are better ways this is
unamerican telling people this there are
better ways this period is period not
period okay period shut the [ __ ] up kind
of a [ __ ] [ __ ] uses that to give a
lecture anyways oh just got a message on
Facebook's call me I lost all my
contacts there oh how do I know this is
from my friend you never know anyways
this is the this is the Monday morning
podcast everybody go [ __ ] yourselves I
have a great couple of days I'll check
in on you on Thursday and don't forget
to get your stockings